Okay--I'd like to teach you about a new concept.
These are called "HTML Attributes".
They look something like this.
We still have our opening TAG name
and our closing , as before--with the slash.
But we have a new thing, called an "Attribute".
Attributes have a name.
In this case, I just called it: ATTR equals--
and then you've got quotes, and a value is inside the quotes.
And attributes, these days, always equal a value.
It didn't used to be the case, to be honest, but everything we're going to do
equals a value.
And tags can actually have multiple attributes.
An example of a tag that uses an attribute
is the Anchor tag--which is the tag.
And a full example looks something like this:
You've got the opening "
you've got an attribute called "href",
you've got its value--which, in this case, is a URL;
you've got the contents,
and then you've got the closing anchor tag.
So if we were to render this in HTML, we would just
see the word, "derp"--but it would be a link to "reddit.com".
Anchors are for making links.
Let's play around with this in our browser a little bit
and see it in action.
Okay. So we've got our HTML from before.
I'm going to clean out some of these tags here
so we have a little bit more room to work.
Let's make the words "HTML", here, a link.
So we're going to make an opening tag,
an "href" to "www.w3c.org/html",
and a closing tag.
When we render this,
we see that HTML has turned into a link
and if I were to click this
it would open this page--"w3c.org"--
and a new window--pretty neat, huh?
Okay. So quick quiz:
Take the phrase below--
we'll take the words, "my favorite" from the phrase below--
and make those words a link to "udacity.com".